Does the United States need to launch a
commercial wharf?
Is the US economy in danger due to the
high trade deficit that they carry with
them each and every year?
It's China competing in an unfair way,
and how can Donald Trump defend the
United States?
Hey,
I'm not saying they're stupid.
I like China.
I sell apartments for 10.
I just sold an apartment for $15,000,000
to somebody from China am I supposed to
dislike,
but we can continuously have other
nations taking advantage of the United
States like never before.
The biggest bank in the world is from
China.
For many years,
no president wanted to go against China
economically and we're going to do it
because we can't continue to allow China
to rape our country and that's what
they're doing.
In particular with China,
we're going to be doing a section three.
Oh,
one trade action.
It could be about $60,000,000,000,
but that's really just a fraction of
what we're talking about.
Dear viewer intentions are certainly one
thing and results.
Well,
that's entirely another.
That's precisely what almost always
happens with protectionist policies.
That ranger to doing one thing,
but they end up doing something totally
different.
Donald trump was very clear about this
during the election campaign that led
him to the White House and he has
continued to be justice clear since he's
arrived in the Oval Office.
Protectionist policies are a fantastic
idea.
I want
those companies and they're starting.
I want them back here.
They're going to come back here to
trump.
Signed new tariffs on steel and aluminum
into law.
Trump moves to crack down on China trade
with $60 million in tariffs on imported
products.
Trump proposes $100,
billion dollars in additional tariffs on
Chinese products.
So far,
only the first terrorist have been
approved such as those on steel and as
an alum,
and it excludes many us allied countries
so that steel and aluminum,
your country is not the same.
That's according to the news.
Trump is very,
very clear about one thing and that one
of his main priorities is fighting the
external deficits.
That is reducing the difference between
imports and exports.
This is a difference of over
$500,000,000,000
every.
Yeah,
and that is where terrorists boys come
into play.
It goes something like this,
so my people,
they want to buy foreign products.
Fine.
Terrorists will teach them about that.
All right.
All right,
hold on.
Let's.
Let's be fair.
Many argue that trump doesn't really
want to get involved in a full blown
commercial.
Warren,
theU ,
s presidents threats especially against
China.
Nothing more than a gamble to force Xi
Jinping's governments into sitting and
negotiate and yeah,
that might be saved,
but since one never really knows with
trump just in case and to clear things
up,
I think we need to ask ourselves a few
important questions.
Does it help the United States open fire
and trigger a trade war tariffs?
Really the best way to help the US
economy is China breaking the rules.
Are they competing in an unfair way and
do we need to punish,
but using.
Well,
let's see.
Wall Street
took a hit today.
The new news of the terrorists from
China took it pretty hard.
China's Ministry of Commerce as it is,
imposing tariffs on 128 American
products sold in China.
China announced a 15 percent tariff on
us,
fruit wines,
steel pipes,
and other products.
This is in response to trump
administration tariffs on aluminum and
steel imports from China and other
countries.
Bad Plan for nonexistent.
Here is a question,
what does a politician want when he puts
protectionist policies on the table and
no,
I know what you're thinking and I'm not
going to accept a winning votes as a
valid answer.
Yeah,
so look,
I know winning votes is every
politician's number one priority,
but for that very reason that's not
sheet.
Let's focus on the specifics of
protectionist policies.
Well,
I think we could say that the objectives
are usually this defending industrial
jobs,
punishing alleged unfair competition,
usually by poorer countries and boosting
the local economy.
Right?
Are those are the intentions,
but what are the results?
If the United States starts a trade war
with China,
is it going to achieve those objectives?
Well,
let's have a look at this step by step.
First of all,
this is what Donald Trump has to say on
the matter.
Under my administration,
the theft of American prosperity will
end.
We're going to defend our industry,
create a level playing field for the
American worker,
Donald J dot trump.
Wow.
Thank goodness that politicians are here
to defend the American,
be both.
By the way,
this is absolutely the same excuse he
uses to prosecute immigration,
defending that American worker,
but there is only one problem and to be
fair is very big problem and that is
that the statistics show a completely
different situation.
You see the US labor market is
undergoing one of the best moments in
almost two decades.
The unemployment rate is at about four
percent and the number of unfilled
vacancies is growing enormously.
Indeed,
the American economic machine is
actually beginning to suffer shortages
of one of its most important inputs and
that's of course
if migration
policies do not change in the economy
doesn't collapse.
Of course,
it is estimated that in the next 10
years the United States will have more
than 8 million jobs to be filled,
and this is actually happening quite
intensely in the Midwest.
Instincts like Wisconsin where there's a
lot of employment,
but very few workers.
It's great to have more people working
in Wisconsin than ever before,
but it creates a challenge.
We just essentially need more people.
Trisha Brown,
chief operating officer for the
Wisconsin Economic Development
Corporation right now.
Unemployment rates in those states,
it below three percent and the new jobs
are constantly emerging.
For example,
the Taiwanese technology group,
Foxconn,
is investing more than $10,000,000,000
in a gigantic campus.
Do developments,
produced new smartphones,
tablets,
and television screens.
It's going to employ more than 13,000
people.
The situation is so peculiar that state
authorities have been forced to launch
an advertising campaign,
for example,
on trains in Chicago and indeed here on
Youtube in order to attract workers to
the state,
but not only that you seek.
The truth is that the manufacturing
industry now employs a lot fewer people
than it did two decades ago,
but do you think this is actually due to
Chinese competition?
Yeah.
Well,
the reality is the numbers tell quite a
different story.
Not only his employment at its highest
levels in US economic history,
industrial production has also reached
its highest levels.
Yes,
the industry has fewer people,
but that doesn't mean it produces any
less.
What's happening is the factories thanks
to robots and technology are becoming
increasingly productive.
So,
uh,
how about an example of this?
Let's take a look at the steel industry,
which trump said is being threatened by
Chinese competition.
Indeed,
his stated that this poses a danger to
national security.
Well,
the truth is that the US produces 70
percent of the steel it consumes for
which only three percent is actually
intended for military use.
So him saying national security leads me
to the reply,
rarely ends on top of that.
China,
it's not even in the top 10 suppliers.
Yeah.
Employment in the steel industry has
decreased to almost half in the last 10
years.
But folks,
the vast majority of jobs aren't lost
due to China or international trade,
but simply due to technology and look a
commercial war.
It's not gonna change that spots,
as you can probably see,
this isn't precisely bad nowadays in the
United States,
there are more jobs than ever.
And the trade deficits,
well,
despite what trump might say,
isn't really that high.
Being less than three percent of the GDP
and in fact it has decreased
considerably in recent years.
Yes.
We're all saying ready for getting some
other important details.
Like for example the investments.
You heard that right?
The United States has a positive net
investment balance.
That is foreigners invest more in the
United States than Americans do abroad,
which is obviously very good for the US
economy's future in 2017.
This positive balance surpassed
$250,000,000,000.
Anything that's all.
Well you are very,
very wrong.
Now we've don't know if a commercial
wall would decrease the external
deficits,
but it would have other not exactly
desirable consequences,
so well,
listen up to this
consequences.
Let me say it loud and let me say a
clear.
The ones who'd be most effected by a
trade war against Chinese imports would
be u s companies.
Yes.
You had that rise.
I did not screw it up.
Buying cheaper materials abroad
decreases production costs for local
industries,
and if in addition,
a foreign country in this case trying to
sell it below cost,
it'd been like Beijing was subsidizing
American Industries at this point.
You might be thinking,
well,
this sounds really good about,
is it actually right?
Well,
take a look at this
now.
We need to bear in mind that the United
States not only important products to
consume from China,
they also important many intermediate
goods and capital goods such as
machinery.
In fact,
more than half of all imports from China
corresponds to this type of product.
Sorry,
now comes an essential question.
What with the terrorists actually
achieve?
Well,
it's precisely that it would damage
American companies competitive now it
would increase the cost of producing
much more advanced goods and aspects in
which the North American industry is
currently a leader.
This would mean decreasing their exports
to the rest of the world as well as the
consumption capacity of Americans
themselves and the results of this well,
that's millions of jobs being destroyed,
right?
Example of the new tariff on steel and
aluminium will make production in the
United States of things.
They use steel and minium like cars and
airplanes more expensive and therefore
less competitive.
Will new tariffs have to be set on cars
in order to offset this hire local
production costs.
And this explains why when in 2000 and
to President George W Bush impose
tariffs on imported steel to the toll
was the destruction of 200,000
jobs.
This was a clear backfire if the
intended.
I see.
Yup.
That is another really detail.
Yeah.
When you sat terrorists,
the usual reaction is for the other
posse to defend itself.
I'm not saying it's the right thing to
do,
but it does happen.
The United States announces an
additional $100,000,000,000
list of tariffs.
China has already fully prepared and
will not hesitate to immediately make a
fierce counter straight golfing.
China's commerce ministry spokesman.
Alright,
so let us use the example of Boeing.
China is the largest market today for
this company and in the next few years
it's going to deliver hundreds of new
aircrafts to China.
Well,
it commercial wart would absolutely
damaged their longterm competitive
position,
for example,
other companies such as Abas and
accelerate the development of a local
industry.
Yes,
it does seem difficult today,
but in the longterm,
the consequences could be absolutely
gigantic and that's not even to say that
China could results the other less
orthodox means.
For example,
let us not forget that China is the
largest foreign desk for the United
States.
Would it be good for Washington if China
stopped buying data or if they began
decreasing securities in order to incite
pressure?
Well,
these are pretty obvious questions.
The answer is definitely no.
This is especially due to the huge
public deficit that the current
administration is fueling,
but wait just a moment because there is
something that trump is absolutely right
about,
is trying to breaking the rules.
Trump has one thing,
right?
China isn't precisely a free market or a
country that plays well with others and
it isn't just about the fact that they
have high tariffs or that they favor
local companies.
They're all of them is for example,
a lack mailing.
Large multinational.
For example,
if foreign companies want to sell freely
in China,
they have to ally with local partners,
partners who can access that technology
and Oh yes,
this technology transfer is a problem in
some ways because these Chinese
companies,
than use this technology to grow and
compete.
However technological companies know
what they're getting themselves into
when they access the Chinese market,
it has to be them who decided where to
produce,
how to compete,
and to what businesses to get involved
in.
Of course,
this doesn't mean that the US government
should have pressure or negotiate with
China,
but unleashing a commercial,
what would be a terribly bad solution,
so listen,
as long as it's just threats,
the US,
they're going to be all right,
but they have to be careful not to cross
the light.
This is how a big crisis would start.
Fortunately,
unless trump insists,
it really looks like this isn't gonna
happen.
China initiate WTO dispute complaint
against us tariffs on steel and aluminum
products.
President Xi Jinping announces plans to
open up China's economy,
including lowering tariffs for autos and
enforcing the legal intellectual
property of foreign firms.
Now,
having said all of this,
let's just wait a moment because there
is still a question on the table and
that's how can the United States reduce
its trade deficits?
Well,
the best way to achieve this is with
bets with structural policies,
doing what great exporting powers like
Germany and Switzerland,
it favorite saving and therefore
longterm productive investment decreases
the public deficit which boosts import
consumption bike overheating.
The economy improves the competitiveness
of local businesses
since reducing bureaucracy,
favoring talents attraction,
yes,
immigration and lowering taxes as the
last fiscal reform of the Republican
Party did,
which we talked about in a previous
video.
Those are the paths that should be taken
while they commercial war.
That's going to be just bad for
everyone,
as in any case,
external deficit doesn't have to be bad.
It all depends on how much the economy
grows,
what it is used for,
or what happens with the investments.
Well,
now over to you,
do you favor setting tariffs on China?
Well,
let us know your answer in the comments
below as well as in this survey and I
really hope you enjoyed the video.
Please do hit that like button if he
did,
don't forget to subscribe to our channel
for brand new videos every Monday and
every Thursday.
Don't forget to check out our friends at
the reconsider media podcasts.
They provided the vocals in this
episode,
but we're not mine and as always,
thank you for watching.
Wall Street took a hit today.
The new news that the terrorists from
China took it pretty hard.
China's Ministry of Commerce as it is,
imposing tariffs on 128 American
products sold in China.